what everybody we work on Finity and
today we're going to find out with how
many balls we can play at the same time
let's start off with two balls
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
I think that was too easy for us s two
three
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
Mika do you think we can do it with poor
balls to show we can
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
that went quite well okay so four was
fairly easy now let's try it with five
balls do you think it's possible I
really don't know let's see
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
magnificent marvelous
[Music]
I mean just look at that figure if you
wanna have a skewed us feeling as me you
should drop your rackets in my beard I
mean to do it
try six I think we should give it a go
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
there's no way this is gonna work out
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
no not bad enough we have to go even
worse
[Laughter]
[Applause]
[Music]
I think it was yeah my pot yes so this
was our best shot playing with as many
balls as possible hope you enjoyed it
remember subscribe here and watch our
previous episodes there until next time